need motivation watch a top 10 with the
leave nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself so get ready for some
passionate rules for success from Gary
Vaynerchuk to give you the motivation
confidence and belief that you need ok
let's kick it off with rule number 1
live your hobby most people don't do
their hobbies as their profession but
this is my hobby
this is my passions what I love to do I
love building businesses this is fun for
you like I'd rather be doing this than
playing for money I'd rather be doing
this than skiing I'd rather be doing
this with rock climbing yoga cooking
watching Game of Thrones this is my
hobby and like I keep telling everybody
in the macro to live there
their passion to happiness and I'm doing
it yeah rule number two love working me
my mom and my dad make a joke that we're
working dogs my parents know how to
relax our default is to work we like it
it's our hobby I would like I like to
work I'm sorry I don't want to go skiing
I do not want to go on a yoga retreat
I'm not interested in being on twitch
for nine hours unless I'm
psychoanalyzing the framework of 14 year
old gamers rule number three give value
for free I mean come on it's cool right
now I'm sharpening knife I love this
idea I'm gonna give you a tremendous
piece of advice that to many people that
are ideological and don't actually play
in the game push against but I believe
in it the most
you should go sharpen knives for five
restaurants for free for free okay yep
like what like I spoke for free for the
first thirteen of birth for it no I
actually got paid for the first one good
that's how it also for mmm 13 of the
first 15 times I ever spoke I spoke for
free including paying for my flights
it's one thing to do free work it's
another thing to do free work with heavy
strategy when I do free work I try to
think of two things how much exposure is
it like Tyler will tell you sitting
right here one of the only times I still
do free work is if it's massive exposure
there are 49,000 people in the audience
among and still a lot of explosions you
know like like it's live on you know
it's during the soup I like it like I'll
pay somebody to put me in a Superbowl
commercial right like when they when I
get exposure or and that's where I'm at
now in the for you when you pick these
five restaurants let it be the biggest
restaurants in your thirty mile radius
let it be the kindest let it be somebody
who has the biggest Instagram following
and maybe like whether you know you
never want to give with expectation but
it's it's okay to ask you're like hey
I'd love to sharpen your knives for free
and then like you get in there and the
vibes are feeling good maybe like hey
listen like I hope you enjoyed it like
wouldn't mind to take a picture for my
Instagram which then makes them say oh
we'll put you on our Instagram like you
can be thoughtful and do it the right
way but
nothing else if you do it for free for
five people you've established that you
do it
word-of-mouth is a remarkably
fascinating thing strategic free work is
one of the great moves in our society
rule number four recognize trends you
were talking about sports cards and
heavily to the economic guys why do you
think that you're able to see those
trends I don't know I don't know why
certain things become obvious to me
social media the Internet itself
wrappers you know first of all I don't
predict anything so like there's an
article on Forbes calm right now that
says sports cards up another 15% as an
alternative investment what I'm good at
is actually knowing something's gonna
extend extend I think people see things
that I see I think certain most but I
think I'm very good at understanding if
something's gonna be a fad for a month
or a trend for three years that's what
I'm good at
also if you want to have more confidence
checking my 254 series they're free the
links to join are in the description
below we are strong as we're really
strong we're just being sold that we're
not because there's a lot of money the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
in a success world please understand
that success is happiness not net
dollars in remember 5 don't listen to
others I don't think most people are
actually judging themselves either I
think they're taking the voices of
others to allow themselves to be judged
people like Gary I hear you but what if
you're you know they're like I get it
don't listen to others but what if your
own voice the one in your own head is
telling you you suck or do this and the
other thing I'm like you've taken on the
voice of someone else I really believe
that
and for some reason through self-esteem
serendipity and many other things very I
mean I consciously in third grade
decided to not try in school not because
I was the normal third grader
definitely wasn't it was cuz I was like
this has nothing to do with my life and
I'm gonna start working on my actual
scale and I'm willing to deal with the
judgment of my teachers you know I'm not
fun it is to grow up your whole life and
have your all your friends parents think
you're a loser because the only
framework in society at that time is
your school grades rule number six mark
it properly if you're a national bank
instead of spending fifty million
dollars on television commercials and
nobody sees I'd rather go give a
big-time production company ten million
dollars to be the sponsor of a new show
on Netflix called ATM where the whole
show transpires around ATMs and it is
literally your comeback like actually
not a made-up bank the Ed Sullivan Show
was funded and created by the Lincoln
Town Car Company people forget that
history television started with brands
funding it commercials came later I
believe now that commercials are gonna
be disappearing because we're watching
screaming I do not put I do believe that
Netflix and Hulu and Amazon will test
commercials my intuition is if they're
smart they're gonna do product
integration and I think look let me give
you another one I've always thought that
a like a big car company with like the
trucks should do a show called the
tailgate or the whole show again is that
a tailgate and it's your truck is the
family's truck Toyota Ford and like that
works was how you seen kids watch the
Masters yesterday how mature the whole
brand placement and lack of advertising
becomes it's a it's just it's amazing
what can be done or the new world we
live in on Twitter the number one thing
that people were talking about was Tiger
chewing gum and so we have a gum client
so I called him it's a Sunday now you
got to move fast like hey dude did you
you know like you know like like there's
moat like that I don't if you guys saw
it one of the awards show the Fiji water
girl right the woman Leonard I think
they call it you know like that like
that's moral wit like guys nobody
watches commercials nobody goes through
the American Direct Mail carefully
nobody's going to page 37 of a magazine
looking at the ad carefully like the
world has changed I'm sorry
pharming used to be our number one
industry things happen like Sears was
number one Walter Cronkite was you know
America's dad like things change I'm
sorry things changed things have changed
rule number seven be passionate
sometimes when I talk to Caleb or
anybody on my team like you know I the
breakout personality in the business
space in this last couple years while
actively being a CEO and CEO of a
massive company and when I talk to them
like could you imagine if I was just
Gary be like every morning I would do a
morning show from like 8 a.m. to 11 a.m.
just QA and would like take you think
I'm penetrating all the channels now
it'd be over I would do it every day
it's my favorite thing to do it you know
he would carry me
you know like nice glass of tea just put
him on call me boom boom boom boom boom
boom clip clip clip distribute
distribute every day look how pumped we
get when we do one of the reasons I did
four DS was for the what I just say
because hiring is guessing firing is
knowing like that thing's gonna kill on
LinkedIn that's 2 million in the bank
rule number 8 put out lots of content no
I do not because I think the
fragmentation of attention is different
than 1984 Madonna could do too much
exposure because there was only 37
places and if she kept doing it we would
get bored in today's world there's so
much as big as I am or as big as a shake
I mean as big as like Drake is like most
like it's so much fragmentation right
like you took you back to hip hop you
look at average fifteen-year-old kids
what they like in hip hop like nobody
knows who they are because they're all
SoundCloud rappers right so like I think
no I do not look the music business is
predicated on a singular hit that
changes the course of your career so why
wouldn't you give yourself 365 chances a
year for that singular hit
right it I'm telling you this is
ideology of the past not this is
everything for me right now in society
and definitely in business we have not
yet as a collective completely
understood what the internet is I'm not
I'm just being very basic like we it's a
young thing well but just like the macro
brother like everything we do is
predicated on a world that was
predicated on print and television and
radio but now the Internet's number one
it is and so every rule goes the other
way because distribution is not limited
distribution was limited in the old
world
so everything was formed around that
distribution in this world it's in
perpetuity unlimited so becomes a game
of best not first they'll never you know
and so yeah I think you should put as
much contest possible rule number nine
be brave if you actually believe
something in a meeting and it might be
against the grain saying it in a
respectful way matters because in three
years when it becomes true the other
seven people in that room will remember
that and that may lead to the growth in
your career that you're looking for
people think they grow in their career
by staying within the framework of their
organization they're actually quietly
subconsciously ruining their career if
they don't agree with the point of view
and I know for a fact because the best
part of can for me hands down is to
three o'clock in the morning when people
have so much rose' in them they start
talking truth I know for I know for a
fact that there's a lot of people that
have strategies or executions they don't
personally believe in it's just a
framework of where the margin is in
their company or what they have to be
held accountable to a bonus and that's a
tough life in in some way in which this
is only just work there's much bigger
things going on but I will say being on
the record in a room respectfully of
what you actually believe brave is a
very very good idea and honestly back to
brave there's so much content there's so
much going on in the world what I think
this room believes that defines us brave
is actually the only prayer to break
through consumer attention to make
something happen in your business and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip is have fun
I was like this story like that you say
that you wore that your first
WrestleMania like when you win
how about this show God decide on your
earth how about this somebody found it I
I haven't seen it yet because I didn't
have the software before now I've been
seen yet huh yeah what I sent you the
best part all right I come down with a
sign that says I love the Jets on this
side crazy literally it makes no sense
Ivan need to hack WrestleManias and push
Jets propaganda that's basically my 20
year plan every 20 years i hack
wrestlemania with jets propaganda I want
to be I'm probably gonna be in
WrestleMania now I've got a special
bonus gift from Gary on how to focus on
improving yourself that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that is time for
the three-point landing questions let's
go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go question number
one
where do you need to be more brave
number two how are you gonna put out
lots of content this week and number
three who do you need to stop listening
to I think we need to have more
conversations around self-awareness and
happiness degrees
people insecure but you don't think
people obviously I mean to point they're
thinking about these things they go they
have the Rose a3 am like oh you mean the
iPods not even like nothing like
marketing-wise like God like it's heavy
for humans but though it's important
right the good news is you don't have to
you can control what you can control
right of course that's it so I can speak
in creative myself but that's what I
live I do what I do and without content
about my beliefs in it some people
connect it then you move forward
ya can't boil the ocean you know yeah I
know it's kind of like shopping do it
just focus on yours do and then you'll
inspire others to do it Evan thank you
so much for having a couple seconds and
being able to tell the believe nation a
little bit about empathy wines it means
a lot to me that you would take this
valuable real estate and and time on
your channel to give me some love
means a lot it's just good karma points
and so you're just you're awesome thank
you believe nation if you're into wine
at all go to empathy wines calm my whole
careers work was poured into producing a
wine that rivaled forty to sixty dollar
wine for twenty bucks a bottle
I'm just super excited about this
subscription-based wine business
you can order three six or twelve
bottles in subscription form Rose a
white red if you could if you search on
Instagram or Twitter you will be blown
away people are literally like I don't
even like Gary B but the wines good
super proud of the effort thanks Evan
for the time wishing you guys all happy
and healthy
if you want more Gary check out the top
50 rules video I made on to him the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
I don't think there's anything wrong
with chasing money I just think that
it's usually the quickest way not to get
it work ethic is controllable